we often hear democrats claiming to be
the more
tolerant party so why are 2020 hopefuls
hurling
violent rhetoric at the president well
joining me now richard goodstein former
clinton advisor
matt schlapp chair of the american
conservative union all right i want to
take you both through some of the
language that trump and the democrat
candidates have been using
over just the past 24 hours now earlier
today
president trump talked about how he was
targeting new states ahead of 2020.
so what her his potential opponents
targeting well
here's cory booker my testosterone
sometimes
makes me want to feel like punching him
okay we really need to play the longer
version of that but what was that
last night that was just a that was an
odd
moment first of all you're not allowed
to make public attacks or references to
attacking the president
second of all their whole thing is about
how trump's language is out of bounds
and he's causing all this hostility this
man's running for president
that's the biggest problem these
democratic candidates have the american
people are practical
do they think these people are ready to
lead with statements like that
richard i mean again the longer version
is actually really hilarious but that
was just as
i it was just a strange moment um your
reaction i kind of know what you're
going to say but go ahead so it's
reminiscent a little bit at women
when trump and biden talked about who
was going to defeat take you out the
woodshed right
um but and i don't think you or matt
quite appreciate this when democrats
hear that crowd channing uh send her
back
and trump sits back there for 13 seconds
does nothing
then the next day says i tried to stop
it like we're all
idiots and blind and there's no such
thing as videotape it does make
people feel um pretty angry is it
is punching him in the face the
appropriate response no but i do think
it
it gives rise to that which is exactly
why i think frankly the republicans lost
the 2018 elections do you mind if i just
say on this whole thing about
how democrats get triggered or upset
about what these
americans 7 000 americans feel can you
understand how upset they are
when they hear the squad and these other
socialist democrats
running down america running down these
american values
that's why they're upset it's not
because they're racist it's not because
they have
they have racial bigotry is because they
don't want people here
that don't appreciate the beauty of
america and they're run they've run this
country down
no more than the president from the
capitol building
talking about american carnage and how
there is no such thing as american
exceptionalism
they've never been that colorful in
running down this country he didn't say
that
he said the opposite he didn't say
there's no such thing as american
exceptionalism i think he was trying to
say that
things have gotten out of control and
we're going to try to get them back in
control and it was a
it's a lofty goal the economy is doing
pretty well and i know we have a lot of
other issues but
i think that's what he was trying to get
out here i want to get to a second
example though here's president trump
today
defending the betsy ross flag after that
backlash
against nike earlier this month how
about the betsy ross
deal it's not terrible where they try
and take your heritage away then you see
the picture of president obama with the
same exact flag up
it's really very unfair what they do
they try and demean
and belittle and they're very good at it
they're better at that than they are at
politics they're better than that than
they are at policy
richard i think when he runs against
colin kaepernick for president
he'll have a great issue i don't hear
any democratic presidential candidate
talking about the betsy ross flagler
they're talking about well truly they're
talking about health care
they're talking about infrastructure all
the things frankly that
announcing this anti-americanism there's
a lot of coming down why is not
every republican denouncing the
president's right to trump
they know he's not a racist well it has
nothing to do with the fact what he's
saying
okay is racist given his history with uh
litany we're not doing let nasa okay
compare that to the 2020 candidate beta
o'rourke watch
um what we saw in north carolina last
week was almost an impromptu nuremberg
rally
matt standing up for the flag versus
impugning americans that's
not a good idea once again their problem
these democratic candidates problem is
not with trump
it's with the american people it's what
these people think that they have the
problem with
and that's the fundamental problem when
they attack those people in north
carolina
they're attacking millions of people
across this country and that's not a
winning strategy
well i think trump taps into the sense
that americans are afraid
that they can't speak without being
branded or racist and they can't think
that america
is worth protecting without being called
the white nationalists i think a lot of
people are just tired of it rhetoric has
to come down on all sides great to have
you both on tonight